he says that his concern is about
harmful emotional academic and
psychological effects of putting
kindergarteners in maths
for hours at a time is there any concern
from officials that you guys talk to in
your
early pre-decisional uh discussions
about that
no there's not and i will tell you from
personal experience my rising
kindergartener told me two days ago
she could wear a mask all day that's
where i get my science
from her kid she never said that
happy monday it's time once again for
it's the cuomo's
starring andrew and chris
cool yes it's the bro with the show and
the bro who won't go
the obnoxious anchor and the political
canker the arrogant hosts
and the governors whose toast the
commentator who's lost appeal
and the creep he'll cop a feel the
chucklehead who blows hot gas
and the fiend who likes to grab don't do
it
an ass sorry so as governor cuomo drowns
in denial how can cnn
manage a smile well they're handling his
brother
the crisis intervention specialist with
kid brother gloves
they sent out that mound of flesh
captain pop and fresh
to attempt to clean up i wonder does
chris cuomo have a lot to say
chris cuomo has a lot to say but right
now he cannot say it
cnn management has made two things clear
to him one that he can't talk about his
brother andrew cuomo on tv
and two that he cannot participate in
any more strategy sessions
with the governor's aides oh it's that
convenient
imagine if cnn used that on everyone
yeah he did something totally
inexcusable but we told him to stop
well wait they did do that with jeffrey
tubin
so i guess it works but think about it a
news anchor helping an embattled
governor to craft responses for an
alleged news outlet like cnn
we always knew dems and the mainstream
media were in bed together but we didn't
know it was
incest cnn's response don't do that
anymore
and also don't talk to anyone either two
things i was once told at an orgy by tom
chalu
come on remember that horrible kissing
montage
talk about a super spreader something
only a tv person would come up with
i couldn't tell if i was watching
cuomo's press briefing or a hot tub
episode of the bachelor
and in all of his seasons a hosting
family feud richard dawson didn't
slobber on as many people as cuomo has
oh man but montages are straight from
the tv playbook and i put
money on chris for pushing the idea hell
he told me to do one for this very
segment
greg gregory john gutfeld
yeah gorgeous
damn i bet he looks great in jeans
oh yeah it's a present for your eyes yes
no no yeah that is disturbing
on many many levels all right
but the good news stelter then said he
talked to his
sources and not the ones at arby's
but i bet that he got some exclusive
facts
this week i've been doing reporting on
the media angle of this cuomo story
which has meant talking with staffers
here at cnn
about chris cuomo and his one-of-a-kind
situation
a tv star in primetime governor's
brother at all times
now let's just be candid with each other
these staffers i'm talking with
are my colleagues of course and i
assured them they could speak
anonymously and candidly
what i found is a more complicated story
than you might think
this has been a conundrum for cnn that
has no perfect answer no perfect
solution
some think cnn made it worse by letting
chris interview his brother
when kobe 19 was ravaging new york uh
you think so
yeah i'd venture that waving around a
giant q-tip while thousands of elderly
are dying in new york nursing homes
probably not making it better i guess
you could have done something worse
though right
do you think that you are an attractive
person now
because you're single and ready to
mingle do you really think
you are some desirable single person and
that this is not just people's
pain coming out of them
i think beauty is in the eye of the
beholder
you know what it did make it worse
anyway what's the big news that you got
brian
but that was an unprecedented time
period and so is this one
a famous family in the news a governor
who soared to the highest heights last
year
now falling to the lowest lows
self-inflicted wounds
and a brother who just wants to do his
job just wants to anchor his show
he just wants to do his job so that's
what you got from your anonymous sources
who happen to be your candid co-workers
that it's like really complicated it's
really confusing like chris just wants
to do his job
well you and earth some real nuggets
there captain crunch
something tells me you just stood around
the vending machine eating funyuns and
you waited for people to come by so you
could say boy this cuomo stuff am i
right
though i can't argue with the anonymous
part have you seen cnn's ratings
screw the witness protection program if
you want to hide from the mob get a show
at cnn
no one will ever find you so
what is brian's big message here chris
is just some hard-working guy who wants
to do his own show which makes me wonder
who was one of these anonymous sources
does it rhyme with klis klomo
this bomo but brian realized something
else that reporting stuff
suddenly is really complicated finally
cnn discovers nuance
equality that was missing when they
covered the police remember the cops
were all guilty and the suspects were
victims
and how about trump voters they were all
bigots right there was no nuance there
in fact if cnn actually practiced nuance
they'd no longer have a network
their business plan is based on painting
everyone with a broad brush
but at least brian can say he tried
my sources say that management has been
clear about its position
he is not covering the governor on tv
period he is not talking about it
at all and you can believe me i tried i
wanted an interview
and i was turned down i bet you really
pushed it
you know it's so convenient that the
honorable rule that chris
stopped covering news about his brother
only came about when that news became
bad
yeah so that was the deep reporting
courtesy of their media reporter who's
clearly spent more time covering his
microwave meatloaf with packets of gravy
than covering what's happening at his
own station
we have a camera in their break room
finally stellar says hey
it's all good because people tuned in to
watch chris
viewers wanted to see him on tv and
let's be honest this is tv so that's not
a totally irrelevant factor
chris had the highest rated hour on cnn
on tuesday on wednesday
and again on thursday there you go it's
not about news it's about ratings
but i hate to tell you they were tuning
in to see if he'd ever talk about his
brother
to pretend that wasn't part of the
momentary ryzen ratings is also to
pretend trump had nothing to do
with their best numbers in years the
best part about this story normally you
don't get to see cable news shape the
news right in front of you
but like a pilot in distress landing on
a highway instead of a residential area
they steer toward one story at the
expense of the other but here you've got
to see them scramble desperately
protecting themselves
you wonder why no one takes cnn
seriously they don't take themselves
seriously
let's welcome tonight's guest she's the
sensation from fox nation
host of monsters across america casey
mcdonald
he's more new york than a rat eating
pizza on hooker's lap
new york city mayweal comedy curtis
lewis
[Music]
like her favorite vape she's fruity and
harmful to miners
foxy's contributor cat tim
and he knows when it's raining before
anyone else does
my massive sidekick and the nwa's world
trans television champion tyrant curtis
when you think in new york we think of
curtis leeway the
the guardian angels you've been around
you've seen it all
this is pretty some pretty crazy stuff
do you think
this guy the governor cuomo is going to
last
well i got to tell you i know the
cuomo's i know where all their bones are
buried and who
buried them first of all
i don't know if you know on wabc talk
radio chris
was actually a partner of mine for a
while oh wow and this is when he was a
legitimate journalist and he didn't have
opinions
yes yes right and they said you're not
good for talk radio now look at him yeah
opinion's a mile a minute but you got to
understand this goes back to his roots
he's a mama luke a mama's boy to matilda
the mother
he's got to prove he's no fredo he's not
going to throw his brother michael
corleone
under the bus right so he's become his
wartime
conciliary you will see i predict
when andrew cuomo is on the outside
looking in they'll be in their compound
out in the hamptons
the only ones who get in the corleone
cuomo compound of
the few friends that are left and the
rest of you the foes
and me of faux for life we're on the
outside looking at it there you go you
know
tyrus there is a point to be made about
family
right yeah that's why i ditched mine um
[Laughter]
16 i was like yeah this thing this ain't
it uh
you know what's funny is going back to
that we'll call it
what was that an interview yes that or
breaking news that
i don't know i just said that b stelter
dropped on us
it was the same montage
that was his brother used except it was
him like
nice pictures with his hands in his
pocket walking in the beach
and his only crime is that he loves too
much i mean he's literally just the
greatest person in the world and the the
toughness of this interview was
he just what chris oh he just really
wants to do his job
and he has so much what i'm saying that
he literally
he the only thing you didn't see was
chris sliding him the paper to finish it
yeah
that was the most complimentary
interview on
something that really should have been
simple if chris cuomo was really about
the people and doing his job i thought
he was the first
guy on the line who says all women
should be heard yeah and listen to
and shouldn't he be supporting that yeah
regardless if it is my brother or not my
brother if he broke the law
or he did these things then he should be
fired that's what a journalist should be
saying
exactly he doesn't want to go on tv
because he thinks it's bad for his
family
they should stealth should have
interviewed him right instead of him
being the host
he could have been the guest he said yes
he's talking about he tried
really hard yes
no the management said no yeah the
management said not chris
he's ready to tell us but now he can be
in he can't be in any strategy meetings
anymore
right right so you can't help out with
that imagine though
well and the aides he can't talk to the
aids but he just lost another one today
yeah
so i don't know how many are left but
imagine if it was
cnn reporting on desantis
yeah and he had a brother at fox right
what would that look like yeah terry
desantis
oh that guy yeah he's a jerk i throw him
to the wolves casey
no but it's a good point i mean there is
no whenever
fox is uh when cnn is dealing with fox
or anything that is non-liberal
it loses all nuance but now the nuance
suddenly
becomes visible because it's it's them
it's things suddenly get really
complicated casey
muddying the water a little bit what do
you make of this cat we've talked about
this we all think he should go he hasn't
gone he's
people are ditching yeah i guess you
know then he'd have to move
moving sucks i get it but he's got to
move out of the mansion
yeah but it's just even stelts are
calling it family drama
yes that really kind of downplays a
little bit right like it wasn't like you
know he was a little rude to aunt
cheryl's new boyfriend at thanksgiving
like he's a serial groping grandma
killer refusing to leave the mansion
even though
everybody says he's got to go so even in
saying
listen we're taking this so seriously in
the same breath he's also downplaying it
too
um it's been a very interesting study of
narcissism to watch he really thinks
he's going to be able to stick it out
he really believes that well don't say
stick it out because well
yeah he's he's running the media cycle
as greg guffield would say you people
are
filthy applauding such degradation
the problem with waiting out the cycles
it doesn't work for him because then
there's just a new bad thing he did yeah
yeah he's facing
seven investigations i still think it's
the i think the nursing homes are still
the
worst than this but we're the only
people that feel that way
murder is tough to beat yeah yeah yeah
exactly
anyway all right it's murder it's murder
before we go we got a huge announcement
we're taking the show on the road yes
this show
one week only and we want you to come
see us we'll be in nashville at the
listening room cafe
september 27th to october 1st to get
your free tickets
go to foxnews.com gut belt look for the
link
on the left side of the page this is
going to be great hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else